[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS moving and storage Studios it's
the Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth new work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money it's a free
call and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Dr John deloney
number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality and host of the Dr John
deloney show a very very popular podcast
on the Ramsay networks is my co-host
today so we're going to be talking with
you again triple eight eight two five
five two two five Ben's in Salt Lake
City hey Ben welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Ben sorry hey Dave and John uh thank
you for your time today sure how can we
help sir
Hey so uh I'll just try to skim over the
top real quick um I am a full-time
single dad
and uh I was on baby step two when I got
sued by my ex for custody and
um so I put everything on hold
um been trying the cash flow through the
process that started back in September
and uh
um basically uh I'm starting to run out
of money and um
and uh I know there's a lot more
expenses coming up I'm looking for a way
to be able to do that because I don't
want to lose my son and um
I'm trying to decide whether to take a
loan or or if I if I can go on anymore
you know what I mean so
what's the basis of the custody suit
um
she just uh so she lives on the other
side of the country and she just wants
to basically flip it uh she
um she said he's not
you know uh
then she did well and and he's
struggling and and things like that but
he's he's doing very well with uh
friends in school and
and he's being taken care of so that's
that's her argument for you but she um
her attitude is basically she's gonna
uh we we tried to work it out inside of
court but nothing it I would be very
surprised if she changed her mind on
that so
yeah I'm sorry
how long have you been divorced
um it's been about three and a half
years where did she get unlimited money
uh her uh her new partner is
um very wealthy
okay all right and I think that's where
a lot of it stems from is the pressure
from uh her new partner because it's
kind of out a character for her to
really go for this but
okay
um well here's the thing
how much you're talking about borrowing
uh about 15 000 and I what happens when
I've had a family member say that they
would uh give me a loan but uh like you
say Thanksgiving what happens when that
runs out
yeah I don't know
so we really have to address this issue
because all you're doing uh it's not
like you're gonna win all of a sudden
with 15 000 more
or if you take out another 10 000 from a
relative after that at the end of that
it's not necessarily like you're going
to win
so it's not it's not a I'm going to lose
custody if I don't take out a loan it's
I don't have a good strategy to end this
if you could tell me that you could take
out a fifteen thousand dollar loan and
100 beat her and it's over
you know I'm not going to tell you to
choose your kid over you know getting in
debt I I don't borrow money I find a way
around it but what's happening here is
that borrowing money is allowing you to
continue in a process that's not got an
end to it because the party on the other
side's got unlimited funds
right
yeah so if you can get some kind of
assurance from an attorney that this is
going to draw to a close there's one
more course of action it's about this
many hours and we're going to be able to
wrap this up that's one discussion uh
I'm just going to keep fighting until I
run out of loans and they never run out
of money
that's not a that's not a that's not a
process that's good for you or anybody
except the lawyers it's good for them
have you tried to roll this into
mediation
because outside and the reason I asked
you why she was suing you because
outside of some egregious abuse or
something else these things are often
handled offline in mediation which has a
an end point and a dollar amount
attached to it
yeah we but I talked to her about that
about a month ago and uh and she gave me
um she just basically
um
told me what she would be willing to do
and it's um you know it's that the that
the custody would would switch over and
yeah but I mean that's the point of
going going through the mediation is one
side says this is all I'm gonna do and
the other side says this is all I'm
going to do and the mediator's job is to
bring people together
but in in in following up what Dave said
the reason I would I would I would push
for that is because it's got It's
there's some finality to it there's a
period in that sentence it just doesn't
go on and on and on and on where is it
being heard in Utah or in her state
in my state okay
all right
um ask your attorney about bringing
about bringing this to a close
and how have you been funding it so far
what do you make a year
about 40 000. okay and you've just been
funding it out of cash flow
yeah
and um so you're out of money why
uh I'm I mean it's I'm I'm still if it
were to just continue with all this
pre-court stuff then I could keep going
but um I asked my lawyer about like
about how much for the rest of it and he
said
um if we go all the way through he
thinks about fifteen thousand
oh he thinks that's going all the way
through okay yeah okay I wish we have a
court date and everything set so
okay
um then what I'm gonna do is take six
jobs and work through the fifteen
thousand if that's it
because that's doable
okay I've yeah I've I've wanted to I've
wanted to do that
um the reason why I haven't done that is
because I also am a student and
um to to just help me um not anymore not
anymore yeah you know take some time off
from being a student right now you're
you're fighting a battle for one thing
so now what we're saying is we're going
to borrow money so we can stay in school
indirectly and we're definitely not
doing that so someone is trying to take
your son yeah that's way more important
than being a student and um avoiding
debt is more important than staying
being a student I also think it's it
will it could I don't say will it could
serve you in court to say I had to stop
doing these things because this person
is dragging me and my child through the
mud and so I had to stop going to school
I had to stop doing this and take more
work on to fund this these accusations
or this this attempt to take my child
from me and I'm gonna do whatever it
takes to keep that from happening yeah
and lean in on your lawyer and say I'm a
guy who makes 40 Grand I don't have 15
grand growing on trees let's figure out
what we can do to clip that that's a
little rich
so uh you know just fulfilling your
lawyers dreams is not one of my dreams
so
oh that's awful Ben I'm so sorry your
face six six for you this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're glad
you're here if you're a new listener and
there are a bunch of you a bunch of new
viewers on YouTube and TBN and all over
the place all our numbers are up across
the board thank you for that a lot of
you are trying to figure out some of the
inside lingo like baby steps and debt
snowballs and all that kind of stuff is
a simple way to do that just go to
ramseysolutions.com click get started
and we'll start walking you through the
process matter of fact we will show you
with a get started process exactly where
you are financially and what to do next
and I help you with your plan your
journey the whole bit click
ramseysolutions.com completely free
no salesman will call completely free
Chris is with us Chris is in Lansing
Michigan hey Chris how are you
hi Dave thank you for having me sure
um I am on baby step six and I kind of
have a two-part question
um my job security isn't too great right
now and I wanted to know should I wait
until I get a new job before I pay off
my house and if I didn't do that what
payments should I get rid of to work
towards
um paying down my house
what payments should you get rid of you
have other dad so I they're like life
insurance uh
401K
um you know the edge 501 like the
educate 529 account tithing so those are
all you know
things that I pay in towards
um that maybe I could redirect towards
my house
okay no way baby step six we would tell
you to keep living your life
and with money you find in your budget
you would pay extra on your house
uh it sounds like this job thing's got
you rattled
how long you been working there
it's my company
for 20 years
and I have a business partner
okay
um so you're not gonna lose your job you
might lose your business is what you're
saying
doesn't leave and I'm the main
contributor
and it's not enough to support
both of us
so slowly
um
my income has gone way down to a point
where I can't really afford not to leave
and he's not leaving so I'm going to
look for something different
what do you do
um it's a marketing company
okay are you married to your business
partner
no no but I am divorced
used to be married to your business
I'm sorry
did you used to be married to your
business partner
no
okay so how is your business partner
squashing your ability to earn a living
um because he's not contributing and
we're 50 50 partners
so he's not bringing in his side of the
business yet he's taking half of what
you bring in and since he's not bringing
any in the the total pie is has shrunk
and he's taking you from closing the
doors and opening a door next door and
just doing this on your own and making
all the money
um our partnership agreement
I basically wouldn't be able to do that
um you have to buy out in order to get
out you have to buy out
uh
uh no you'd have to he'd have to buy you
out
if you want to know that's not how our
partnership agreement is structured our
apartment our partnership agreement is
structured that if you leave
um you by your clients if you were to
take them
but I'm looking to get out of this
industry altogether and start just a
whole different chapter okay so what are
you going to do and what are you going
to be making
um well I'm looking right now but I'm
hoping to
um manage a team of people and be in
sales and
um I'm looking at
around
200 to 350.
Okay so
um this sounds like it didn't just
suddenly occur it's it's crept up on you
and you've you've put off making the
decision
correct you've delayed and so what you
need to do is not worry about your house
and not worry about your tithe you need
to get on the phone today and get a
freaking job Chris it's time to do this
painter get off the ladder today yeah
yeah you you you're you're a year
at least maybe six months late on
someone kicking you and I'm gonna kick
you right now because I love you get
going I'm probably about five years to
ten years later okay then then somebody
needs to break the fog up so I'm your
guy I love you enough okay get going
girl okay you're too sharp to be this
dumb get going get going let's go go I
want you to have this done by the end of
April a new job and say bye bye
April yep you got a month
I got it I got my resume ready you need
to call me back on the air and tell me
you did it I'm gonna hold you
accountable okay
okay
and you need to call uh who is your best
girlfriend that's mean
say it say your name say her name yes
you do yes you do who how many okay what
about your sister she mean
no I want somebody mean I want you to
call them and tell them to call you and
kick you if you don't do this I want you
to declare to the world it's time for
you to Roar again Chris you're meowing
yeah I understand I know that and you
are not a kitten you are a lioness
Am I Wrong understood this thing was
built up by a woman
this whole thing was built up by a woman
of substance this was built by a woman
of substance and yet you have for some
reason you have watched this thing
deteriorate and your life with it to the
point now you're going I don't know if I
need to pay for groceries no you need to
get a freaking job
I know this is what's going on yeah go
get that and all of these other
questions go away don't they
you're 100
that's why I'm here
man if you if hey something I don't hear
at home very often you keep answering
questions like this you're going to turn
this into a job
yeah
so stuck in just the day to the day that
sometimes it just takes someone looking
at you be like what are you doing you
can solve all of it all of it just get
trapped
but you you do need ah you really need
people in your life in your community
that are that love you enough to go uh
I'm watching you do nothing and I'm
tired of it there's that famous uh
psychological study where they took the
dogs and you couldn't do this study now
but they shocked them and
um
they they didn't give them an
opportunity to escape and they had other
dogs that they were shocked that they
would allow to escape and over time they
would take the barriers off the dogs
that they were shocking the dogs just
took it it was just learned helplessness
this is the way this is going to be and
it just you need somebody to go hey go
go you can run and run away then they
take off right just gotta get somebody
to look at you so that's just a fun
thing so yeah
um we all need that though because what
the the fastest way I mean that's
classic uh frog and a kettle thing I
mean fastest way to boil a frog is turn
it up one degree at a time just a little
bit of time gradual gradual five years
this has been deteriorating and then you
look up and you go wait a minute I'm
boiling over here yeah
and this guy's doing nothing and still
collecting half the
house because I'm trapped in a really
stupid partnership agreement hey
I hear this happen a lot people have an
imaginary amount of money they're gonna
make when they leave their job how
tightly do you tell somebody to hold on
to that versus get something and then
begin to maneuver and this one gets
something and then begin to maneuver
yeah but um 253 just like I've been
doing this job for 20 years I'm just
gonna transition
she might I mean in this current
environment where there's such a
shortage of everybody high quality White
Collar people I mean yeah it's she might
I don't know I don't know what her skill
set is but uh urgency is one of them we
got to add back to it yeah yeah here we
go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50 off everything
site-wide visit blinds.com today to
learn more
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Andrew
is with us hey Andrew how are you hi
Dave and John how you doing better than
we deserve brother where do you live uh
Keokuk Iowa all right very good and how
much debt have you paid officer 303 000.
whoa how long did this take 49 months
good for you and your range of income
during that four years uh 37.5 up to
88.5 and I was also doing a part-time
job taking about 15 000 a year home good
for you what was your part-time gig uh
working at a gas station Quick Trip a uh
local uh chain in Wisconsin Minnesota
and Iowa working a lot then uh yeah
every holiday yeah uh every evening
every weekend wow and what do you do for
a living day job uh well actually I'm a
quality control scientist but right as I
finished uh my dad I was uh I was laid
off
um so still looking for a new job there
but in quality control but now you're
three hundred and three thousand dollars
less weight to carry exactly yep good
for you well done what kind of debt was
that uh 93 000 in student loans 28 000
for a home improvement 22 000 for a car
ten thousand in credit card and then 150
000 for a house dude you're dead free
house and everything I I sold the house
but uh to push it off so wow look at you
well done well done
so you're homeless but you're debt free
yeah
yeah we're renting now so okay that's
all right that's all right you're in a
really really good place congratulations
thank you how's it feel uh it feels
great it's uh it's it's amazing you got
wired up about four years ago what
happened what got you started on this
Ramsey stuff I was uh I had I had just
moved up to uh Wisconsin
um in Edgerton Wisconsin just outside of
Madison I moved back to
um Iowa last July
um and just one night in November I was
sitting there looking all my debts and I
was like well this is going to take me
30 40 years and
had to come up with something and uh
your book was on my my shelf uh picked
it up started reading it again I just
remember always uh seeing you like on
Fox Business and stuff like that so just
uh just got the fire lit
so the world's the world's largest uh
coaster was on the on the coffee table
yep yep again we're just waiting for
years for you to open it and do it yep
so uh you reached kind of a moment that
night didn't you yeah I reached uh
definitely interested in I had a moment
and I was just looking at I was like you
know this uh this isn't a good life I
was just uh my my mortgage was probably
40 percent of uh my uh my payment of my
my income and just couldn't couldn't get
there so had to had to clear it up and
that's why I got the part-time job
because I said I needed an extra
thousand a month so dude uh I say this
with all due respect you don't you've
never made a ton of money yep and we
hear people all the time with half or
less of this amount of debt
making six figures making a hundred
thousand bucks and say well I can't do
it I can't figure out how to do it and
you making 37.5 to 88. it's a great it's
a great salary but we're not talking you
didn't do this making 500 Grand paying
off three hundred thousand dollars
um that takes a level of courage and
bravery that most of us don't have I'm
looking at myself thinking if I made 50
Grand I I don't know how I could pull
this thing off in 48 months
what got you going uh just just uh just
keeping them to seeing that hey there's
there's light at the end of the tunnel
there
um it's a dim light yeah you got my uh
um 2019 I didn't uh the debt didn't go
down at all I paid off the credit cards
but the way the student loans were uh
even though making payments it still
just didn't go down wow um but then
really got the fire going
um big cheerleader was one of my friends
Bjorn uh we would just text each other
back and forth and keep each other
accountable he's on four five six so
I would love to see that text chain hey
I hate my life I hate mine too yeah keep
going man keep going yeah actually when
uh you guys are having a sale one time
and and Bjorn and I were talking and I
said you know this isn't the budget for
me right now and uh it was all of your
books and he actually sent it to me uh
as a gift so that was oh wow that was a
great motivation there wow very cool
good for you man I'm so proud of you
thank you thank you other than Bjorn who
was your biggest cheerleader uh my dad
was a good cheerleader um and then but
yeah just just kept going there she came
with you today he did he did good so
where are you living now uh living I
live in Keokuk renting a house for my
brother actually okay so okay all right
and gotta land in a new position and off
we go into Prosperity yep absolutely
yeah ever go back into that oh no no
never again
what do you tell people the key to
getting out is uh definitely the budget
um and just and just sticking to it uh
you know there's going to be days where
you want to give up but where you're at
that point where you gave up you wanted
to keep going so just remember why you
started and just keep moving forward if
four years a long time yes it is a long
time and it's really not that long in
the scope of your life no no you know
maybe five percent of my life you know
if I make it to 80 so there you go uh
short short time blink of an eye what do
you tell somebody staring like just
speak directly to that camera what do
you tell somebody who's staring at 250
300 400 000 and they're not making 350.
you know once once you get motivated
once you get started on it that's when
the the promotions will come in that's
when uh the money will come in because
once you clean up one part of your life
other parts will get cleaned up too yeah
amen well good for you brother thank you
very very proud of you so we've got the
uh live and give box for you the bundle
the baby steps millionaires book
um that's their next chapter in your
story The Total Money Makeover book for
you to give to somebody and uh maybe
you'll be Bjorn for somebody in there
there we go and Financial Peace
University membership as well so if you
haven't been through the class it's time
to go through it now make sure you
finish this process out I'm very proud
of you brother thank you thank you Dave
very well done very very impressive good
good stuff
all right it's Andrew from Iowa 303
000 paid off in 49 months including the
sale of his house was 150 of that making
37.5 to 88.5 count it down let's hear a
debt free screen three two one I'm debt
free yeah
foreign
[Music]
you know I think uh uh we've always
worked with uh obviously married couples
and singles as well for 35 almost 40
years now walking them through this
process
um
in some ways being single like him and
doing this is easier because you don't
have to talk somebody into it yeah but
in other ways it's uh you don't have to
you don't have anybody to kick you
there's no no accountability there's no
camaraderie uh it gets a little you know
when you fight for 48 months I can get a
little lonely yeah yeah I mean thank you
may have Bjorn which is backing him up
by text and became his community in that
process and you got to have that and I
don't care I don't care who you are
it's hard to keep eating right for 48
months it's hard to keep exercising
every day 48 months it's hard to pay off
debt and having having somebody right
there with you I I think it you're right
it's harder to stay on the tracks but
man it's easier when somebody's just
walking there with you yeah but I mean
it's a different dynamic uh to go
through this transformational process to
clear the debt so stick with it for a
married couple than for a single each
one has its own advantages and
difficulties so uh like you're not
you're you're not uh you haven't got it
easier but you haven't got it that much
harder you just got a different kind of
heart there you go when you're single or
when you're married and it's all of it's
hard but there's a process and so
sometimes it's hard you gotta talk
somebody into it you know you're
dragging along the spouse you're trying
to get them involved you know you just
you know you can't seem to get them it's
dead weight you're dragging uh and then
on the other hand the other way you're
like man I wish I had some help here I
wish I had somebody you know to tell me
to do this so there's different kinds of
hard but it's worth it and uh but for me
watching someone like him uh that's a
particular kind of hero yeah this one's
hard I I think back to the time when my
wife and I owed six figures
and we're living in a residence hall
I and I we we made good money our
combined salaries and I didn't know how
we're gonna do it and to look at to be
able to say I'm making 37.5 and I've got
a 303 000 hole I'm going after it that's
it that's a level of strength and
bravery and commitment that inspires me
even to this day amen like man there's I
don't care how small I am I'm gonna get
in the ring I'm gonna hit that dude
right I'm gonna try to knock him down so
the point for those of you
that our listening or watching is
you too can do it
we don't go with excuses around here we
don't even go with reasons you can do it
you can do it people just like you have
done it we've been doing this a long
time I don't care who you are Someone
Like You has done their dead free scream
I really don't care
yes you can
now it's time
it's your turn ready
Set Go
[Music]
thank you
with debt payments
and now with inflation stealing more and
more of your paycheck we know a lot of
you feel like you're drowning and you're
scared to death I've been there myself
it's no fun
doesn't have to be that way though
you can say just like our last uh Dead
free screamer Andrew I've had it not
living like this anymore
and we can show you how to do some new
things with your money that you've never
done before that'll cause you to be able
to win they're nothing really Earth
shattering it's basically common sense
but we uh not only show you what to do
we help make you do it it's called
Financial Peace University it's a nine
week nine lesson course that'll teach
you how to beat debt build wealth and be
outrageously generous
it's everything you wish you'd learned
about money nearly 10 million people
have been through Financial Peace
University FPU and now they're in
control
and they got margin and you can too
so decide that you're done with money
stress
the sides you're done and you're going
to take control start Financial Peace
University at ramseysolutions.com FPU
ramsesolutions.com
FPU Jessica is with us she is in Jeff
oops that's not Jessica let me try again
Jessica's with us in Jeff City Missouri
hey Jeff Jessica what's up hi thank you
so much for taking my call today
um I'm in a rock and a hard place I want
to have another baby but I also want to
go back to school to get my income up
and we don't really know what to do
which one do you want more
both at the same time both and
why can't you do them both at the same
time
um we have two children now and we just
got out of debt on the first so we're
trying to build our emergency fund to
learn baby step three
um and we have health insurance
yeah how much it cost to have a baby
like 10 grand no it doesn't not out of
pocket
I did for us the last two we did you
have horrible insurance
uh it doesn't cost but 10 grand to have
a baby
yeah well we there was I was in the
hospital a lot with both our kids so
um was covered in health issues while I
was pregnant so oh okay so we had
Extended Stay so it's not just a simple
labor and delivery yeah yeah okay
you anticipate that this time as well
possibly
I'm healthier but possibly so I would
prefer to put anticipate it than not
yeah it could happen that makes sense
which helps it not to happen because
you're not stressed you know that makes
sense yeah I'm not as stressed so that's
good but
um
are you working right now
yes is there a way to split the
difference and you and your husband uh
really get fanatical and put three or
four or five thousand bucks in an
account
and just pause everything and store up
some cash
but they give you some peace
yeah we can he wants 30 000 for our
emergency funds well I want a pony too
and sometimes you know what I mean
I don't actually want a pony at all
actually not even a little bit but okay
weird but I mean I mean you can I mean
you can wish all kind of things but
sometimes it's going to take a minute to
get there
in your emergency fund you'd be well on
your way if you want to keep going
towards 30 that's fine is that necessary
before you had a child no it's not
okay
um and so but I think you do need to
so the answer is how are we going to do
all these things in order
not all at once when you try to do them
all at once it's impossible because it's
overwhelming and you simply don't have
the bandwidth of time energy money to do
just say Oh by the end of April we'll
have all of this going no you're not
you're not going to graduate from school
have a baby by the end of April it's not
going to happen so why don't we just say
which one is Lee is going to happen
later than the other one and I don't
care it's your life so I mean like we're
gonna have our baby first and during the
time that we're having that child a nine
month time frame we're going to finish
up this emergency fund and get it up to
15 to 30 000 during that time and then
after the child comes home and I'm able
to get back to work and then I'll start
talking about going to school or I'm
going to put off having a kid to get my
degree finished I don't care which one
but just decide so it's not no it's not
now
yeah I just wanna I feel like I'm not
contributing if I'm not working and if
we have another baby day care costs are
expensive too so then so here's what I
don't want you to do just I don't want
you to circumvent that concern
because that that I that idea that I'm
not contributing is something it it's in
the air we breathe when it comes to
making women feel guilty on if they
choose to go to work they choose to stay
at home there's all of his contribution
nonsense that is just pumped at you 24 7
365. you have to make peace with that
because no degree no other kid and
another kid another kid no emergency
fund amount is going to let you sleep at
night because those aren't the issues
the issue is you're looking in the
mirror and thinking I'm not
participating in this household and
that's simply not true
you gotta address that what's your
husband make
uh 80 to 90. does he say you have to be
a financial contributor to you
no okay
so this is you saying this to you or our
toxic culture saying this to you
saying it to me yeah so let me give you
an example okay
um 38 years ago my wife
um 36 years ago I mean my wife went home
when she had our first child
as a full-time mom
and uh has never worked outside the home
since
and one of the reasons that I am a
national brand and a
highly successful business person is
because I don't have to deal with drama
at home she's the opposite of a drama
queen
she maintains the fort and the Fortress
she fights off all the enemies and when
I get home it's a place of Peace not a
place that I have to add yet another
level of stress that has given me a
foundation to come to the office and
fight the dragons every day for 30 years
I would submit to you Jessica that
Sharon Ramsey is a contributor
yeah
to our wealth
yeah you see how that works
yeah she really is I mean that's
legitimate that's not me just
philosophically discussing something
there's an actual factual piece of data
here that says that one of the reasons
we have the money we have is because
I've been able to focus at work instead
of having to deal with a bunch of crap
with some princess at home
and so I call that contributing
and uh so you know did she go out and
make 10 million dollars during that time
no she didn't make a dime during that
time except for Consignment sale
clothing which I still can't get her to
quit doing but um
like we're still broke I mean come on
she still sells our clothes give them
away but anyway yeah she because she
wants to contribute but yeah oh my God
but yeah that's the thing uh so we we
you know we there's mom guilty if you
work and there's mom guilty if you don't
work right and so that that's what
John's it's coming from the outside in
it's coming from the inside out right
exactly exactly because it gets him it
gets planted in you early on and
Sharon's dealt with that Rachel who's a
very very busy career woman Ramsey
personality deals with that uh deals
with it uh you know and talks about it
openly uh you know okay I feel bad if
I'm leaving to go but also this is what
I'm called to do and I'm gonna go do it
and if I didn't go do it I'd feel bad
for not going to do it that's right and
so it's like yeah damned if I do damn if
I don't you know it's just and so at
some point you've got to work through
that and make peace with it and then
that allows you to decide why I'm going
back to school that's exactly right and
in that it that order you're talking
about it tends to line that order up
pretty easily sometimes
um if you you're trapped in a story that
you're telling yourself I'm only worth
this or my only value is this or I'm not
contributing there's something really
powerful about writing that down and
reading that to your spouse especially
in this situation where there's not a
spouse like man you need to get off your
butt and get a job and there's two
there's you know two kids and a third on
the way that idiot that doesn't sound
like her husband at all no it sounds
like she's telling herself a story and
he doesn't make a bad income you know
he's doing fine he's doing fine
especially you're gonna you're gonna
have a mad house of three young kids
running around and no one's no one's got
a lot of money with all that that's
that's life
um but he's not he's doing well but I
think sit down and tell him that hey I
don't feel like I'm contributing let him
respond like you did and sometimes there
is a sense of peace that we didn't even
know was there you know when we were
doing it I'm not sure I really grasped
but I didn't care I didn't I didn't care
but when I look back on it now I'm 100
sure I'm Dave Ramsey that everybody
knows
because of because of what she took care
of at home no it would not have happened
otherwise if I had to deal with what
some of my buddies have had to deal with
oh my Lord
yeah no question in my house this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today number one best-selling author and
host of the Dr John baloney show if
you've not checked it out it's on all
things mental health and relationships
and uh quite a lot of stuff going on on
this podcast you should check it out
it's a lot of fun and it's one of our
more popular things we're doing around
Ramsey's networks these days so be sure
you do phone number here triple eight
eight two five five two two five Leon is
in Philadelphia hi Leon welcome to the
Ramsay show hi Dave hi John how you all
doing better than we deserve what's up
hey I was calling today to see if uh we
should allow finances to stop my wedding
plans
that's a broad question can you tell us
more yeah absolutely so my fiance and I
have been together for a long time
um she's desired to get married uh more
than I have or more more time than I
have
um it took our return to faith and our
my fiance's bravery during the pandemic
to really open my eyes to marriage
um
our opinions diverge in one area
um and and that's our approach to
marriage I'm more pragmatic with my
Approach and she's more idealistic
um in preparation to in preparations to
get married I did some math
and uh realize that in getting married
um some of our expenses will increase
significantly in particular our health
coverage
um my fiance uh qualifies for a no-cost
medical insurance right now through the
state and um
in the event that we do get married or
when we do get married
um that that expense will increase
significantly it'll go from about
um 104 a month to about 510 a month my
employer funded uh health insurance
um to add a spouse that it it jumped
significantly so sure what's your
household income
um we're at about 62 000 a year you're
not honestly honestly asking us if your
wife is your wife if her becoming your
wife's worth 4 800 a year
well it's it's a little more than that
yeah it might be 40 814 come on super
nerd really
well the deductibles will also double
you're killing me
listen hey here's the deal no you should
not get married
you should not no absolutely not
if you're gonna nickel and dime your
relationship with this woman that has
has suggested she wants to spend the
rest of her life with you even the way
you said I came around to marriage
because I saw she was Brave and
um something that like
I want the hounds of Hell holding you
back from wanting to be with this person
forever
and forty eight hundred dollars dude
I've seen guys way make way like making
stupid Financial moves because they were
so head over heels they were going to
marry somebody that I had to say whoa
whoa slow down
forty eight hundred dollars sounds like
you are looking for a mathematical
reason to not do this is what it sounds
like
um It Isn't So we have a child together
okay and um we kind of went went about
our our family a little bit backwards
um so we purchased the house we have a
family together and it really is our
plan to be a single single income
household
um with with me working and and she's
staying home and helping to raise our
son with me
um so it's it's not just the I I know
that if we pursued
um plans in a more traditional way Leon
how old are you 40. are your mom and dad
still married
no nasty divorce
no um I was young
hurt you though
um yeah yeah it definitely did and um I
do think it had an impact on my view of
marriage in terms of you know
what so you're looking for a way to
intellectualize
a spiritual and emotional decision
yes and um
your your the John's point is the best
thing you can do and it will actually
cause the math to work out there's an
odd odd piece of uh irony here but the
best thing you can do is go all in it's
time to get off the ladder time to stop
painting painter get off the ladder it's
time to do it dude you have a baby you
own a house in every form you're married
except in your emotions where you have
finally let go of that last little piece
of control and that last little hurt
little boy named Leon from his mom and
dad's thing and it scared him and it
hurt him and that doesn't make you bad
it doesn't make you weak it just makes
you a human
and it's time to let go of all that and
marry this woman and enjoy her and enjoy
life together and enjoy a wonderful
future and lean into the emotional
relational spiritual part of that and
then there is actual data that's called
the marriage advantage
this that shows statistically that
married couples end up with a higher
probability of wealth and a net worth
and a higher net worth than singles
particularly singles shacked up
and so the data is actually there the
research is actually there to back this
up that's right and it goes back to you
and I were having a conversation earlier
um on another show about
um
Sharon's work at home allowed I mean
whether it's somebody contributing
directly cash into the account or
whether somebody's creating a platform
for uh somebody else to to repel off the
side into
um man it it works out that way it just
does yeah you're you're gonna you're
gonna Prosper more than the
supposed loss that you have identified
yeah and mathematically that's going to
end up being true
um I can't I can't it's
um
difficult to put actual actual examples
in place today
but I do know that the research says
that and I do know that my 30 plus years
of doing this helping people with money
shows that a fully committed couple in a
marriage that have shared goals and
vision
and are both working towards the same
thing and um one of them's neither one
of them are dead weight they both are
are contributors to the discussion
contributors to the dream that there's
just a trim you know the career is
better the health is better the um
obesity is lower the uh blood pressure
is lower the everything and all that all
of that by the way ends up affecting
your dollars and cents absolutely so
there's a whole thing there and then of
course this idea that that you know two
horses pulling together in tandem one
plus one equals more than two and we all
know that's called Synergy yeah that's
right
um and if you notice if you listen back
to the call Dave I it's an old counselor
trick but when somebody comes and asks
like I'm kind of stuck I don't know if I
should do this I should do this
if you'll just say well go and break up
sometimes they'll exhale and sometimes
they'll come back and be like I'm not
breaking up and there's your answer
right and so there's a push it's it's
just an old well then you're not ready
to get married and if the first impulse
is yes I am then there now you're you've
intellectualized it you need to get on
that track and if it's you're right I
don't need to get married then you've
answered your own question yeah but you
also by asking these questions Leon
you've identified some things you all
have the opportunity to work on some
healing in absolutely that'll uh that'll
release a lot of positive stuff in your
relationships and in your money this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
well in one month we're going to have
our inaugural event at the Ramsey Event
Center it's a smart conference that has
got about four tickets left I think it's
just basically sold out if you want to
come you can get one but more
importantly we're going to use that same
uh Event Center which is really looking
cool I was up there a while ago we're
excited because this is opening week for
us with the thing but we're going to do
a marriage and a money and marriage
weekend getaway
in Nashville at our Event Center October
19th and 21st with uh Dr John deloney
and Rachel Cruz it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be a blast
so uh communication doesn't always equal
connection and whether you've been
married five or 25 years not uncommon to
get complacent in the day-to-day routine
and so uh Rachel and you you're going to
tear into this that's right we're going
to talk about getting in line so we're
talking about intimacy we talk about
money how it all works together and um
I've been hearing all over the country
married couples have become roommates
um inadvertently so just trying to deal
with coven the pandemic and jobs and
moving all that and this is a chance to
focus on yourself for the first time in
a long time October 19th through the
21st it's an entire weekend the money in
marriage getaway weekend in Nashville
you'll not only get to enjoy our
fabulous City and there is a lot of cool
stuff here but uh of course get to enjoy
this entire event the entire weekend is
6.99 a couple three full days of amazing
content food and all the cool surprises
that we've got waiting on you because we
know how to do this and it's a lot of
fun this is a serious deal it's a great
great deal so listen only a limited
number of tickets so check it out today
ramseysolutions.com events the money and
marriage getaway weekend October 19
through 21 next fall in the brand new
Ramsey Event Center and again an entire
weekend here in Nashville and you're
gonna gonna have a last looking forward
to having all of you all right up next
is Christina in Cincinnati hi Christina
how are you
I'm doing well good how are you better
than I deserve what's up
uh so quick question I am expecting to
be out of baby step three here in the
next few months
um and I don't know if I should be in
babysit 3D or if I should start baby
steps four and five
and also if I'm to start the investing
baby step if I use my dad who's a
financial advisor who is well known in
the town or if I use one of your smart
master Pros
okay how old are you
26. okay
why would you not use your dad
he won't go along with that
the cards but like he pays them off now
your financial advisor doesn't control
your credit cards
not right your financial advisor handles
your Roth IRAs
Christina does your dad give you advice
on a lot of things that you don't ask
him for advice on
no
why are you it seems like the question
behind your question is that you don't
necessarily want your dad dealing with
your money is that right or wrong
I don't have an issue with my dad
dealing with my money I've been waiting
to go over to his house to have him
really like
you can't take my budget really so
I don't know I it's something that I've
been contemplating like do I go with my
dad or do I use one of your smart
investors just because like I'm very
into if your dad will allow you to make
your own decisions and will do what you
tell him to do with your money
you would use your dad
unless he's not a person of Integrity or
you have some kind of a relational
violation with him but if he has control
freak issues or if he's got boundary
issues and he's going to tell you what
you have to do and if you don't do it
the way he wants he's going to use his
dad voice then then you would not use
your dad or if he's going to move you in
funds and just let you know hey I went
ahead and moved all this for you because
I saw some in the market then that a
Trader like a smartvester pro would
normally call me and say hey I'm
thinking about doing this I want to
recommend this what do you think
um
that he will let you be an adult and
make your own decisions and he follows
the fine he makes suggestions and then
does what you tell him to do with your
money after you've had his teaching and
his advice and his suggestions then
that's a healthy reasonable boundary
situation you have no relational
breakdown with him otherwise then I
would use your dad
that's how I would do it no question
about it if he is if he's saying listen
you need to buy this whole life life
insurance policy and you say no I don't
use whole life life insurance and he has
a fit and acts like you're 14 years old
then you don't need to use your dad yeah
but but I don't hear that here
I I kind of think we're being tested to
see if we send everybody to smartvest
approach no matter what but
um I don't I mean it's it's there's
nothing wrong as long as you're a
financial advisor is not confused about
who owns the money but I mean financial
advisors cfp sometimes means Certified
Financial Pharisee sometimes it means
certified financial planner and they
actually will teach you things uh but
some people in that business they get
like a doc syndrome and they're like I'm
God now and you need to listen to me
that's right uh whether it's your dad or
not right and so that's why we always
tell folks you're looking for someone
and while we vet our smart investor
approach you're looking for someone that
has the heart of a teacher not the heart
of a Salesman or a control freak because
the first time one of these characters
in the financial world or in the legal
World tells me what I have to do with my
life instead of suggests that here's a
wise course of action then our that we
just were done yeah I'm done yeah and I
my my smart investor for pro is an old
friend and I said hey I don't I don't
you don't have to do your Spiel I just
want you to do I want you to do this and
he said I don't do that I teach and it
was a it was a this is like I'm not
gonna do business with you if you want
me just to run your life my job is to
teach you what's going on with your
money and so I really appreciate the
pushback it was good no that's because
he doesn't do it the other way that's
and there really is only two types of
people in the financial world and that's
the two types so yeah I mean it's
perfectly fine to do that but what I
often run into is is there's a
you know her like you know Dad pouch or
something like that and I'm like we
ain't part of my advice you know and so
uh you know they follow Dave and that
somehow is a judgment or an indictment
against you Dad and I don't ah man you
use credit card points I'm not I don't
want to deal with I don't I don't want
to deal with that that world I'm not
gonna argue with you about it I'm just
gonna do what I'm gonna do exactly yeah
that's the thing Hannah's with us in uh
Grand Rapids Missouri Grand Rapids
Michigan I'm guessing what's up Hannah
hi Dave and John it's great to talk to
you both of you you too how can we help
so I drank the Ramsey Kool-Aid about a
month ago and welcome welcome yeah man I
keep drinking it too
so I am on baby step two but I actually
have a question on baby stuff one
because I have the thousand dollar
emergency fund for a little bit I was
trying to continue to save for a house
while trying to pay off debt and you
know how well that worked out
that was before you took the last step
of Kool-Aid yeah yeah
so I ended up having three thousand
dollars in car repairs done this last
week
um which is obviously over the thousand
dollar emergency fund and thankfully I
had that house savings quote unquote to
use for the used car repairs but I'm
wondering if you have a more reasonable
starter emergency fund while I sit in
this paying off debt phase because
man I can't go through that if I only
have a thousand dollars left in there
how many times do you think you're going
to have three thousand dollar car
repairs
I think we can agree that's
statistically highly unusual
that is true but you know I have I'm a
single person one income I you know I
don't live with roommates I have two
dogs that are very expensive if they
ever go to the vet for an emergency what
do you make so
I
pre-tax 62.5 and how much debt do you
have
about 8 200 in student loans
my last one your thousand dollar
emergency fund's not supposed to be
reasonable I want it to burn it's
supposed to be unreasonable it's
supposed to be like I'm a little scared
so I'm going to get my butt in gear and
pay off 8 200 really really really
really really really really fast
let's have a garage sale this weekend
let's take three jobs I want this done
in two or three months and then build up
your emergency fund to what it should be
yes it should be uncomfortable yeah it
should be unreasonable to you that
you're sitting in debt
that's what's unreasonable
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author host of
the Dr John deloney show is my co-host
today the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five our new
sponsor for our question of the day we
are so proud to have a neighborly your
hub for Home Services sponsoring our
question of the day the questions
brought to you by neighborly when
something in your home breaks neighborly
is the name to remember and with a
neighborly Done Right promise you'll get
great service from their network of
local home service providers people like
Mr Rooter Mr Electric Molly Maid these
are names you've heard of they're all
part of the neighborly Hub so be sure
and check them out at neighborly.com
today
all right today's question comes from
Daniel in the Ramsey Baby Steps
Community Daniel writes I have a problem
I'm hoping you can help my wife is not
on board with doing the baby steps in
her head it's basically your debt not
mine I've tried talking to her but she
always ends up getting mad and not
wanting to talk about budgeting or
financial goals at times it feels best
if we parted ways and I'm alone on this
journey yikes man you already are yeah
exactly
um you're alone and you're dragging
somebody along with you uh Dave anytime
this conversation needs to be happened
way ahead of way way before budgeting
our financial goals this is not a baby
steps or financial problem this is a
broken marriage yeah exactly this is um
somebody who's either because of
childhood stuff or because of recent
stuff or because of the way Daniel does
communication she has created her own
little Universe inside this marriage
inside this house and does not want
anybody coming in or out of those walls
and that's the conversation that needs
to happen yeah but it's not like
I'm getting a divorce because of the
baby steps yeah
um you know you're if you're marriage
ends it's because you
refuse to work together on anything I
mean I'm sure baby steps is not the only
thing no it's just the latest place that
has shown up right that um
and Daniel the way you are describing
your wife
is um
you describe her you describe your wife
as belligerent
um and immature
and um
which tells me that there's a level of
contempt
for her and uh as uh Les perrett talks
about in his marriage stuff and he's
quoting gottman the uh Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse uh one of the four things
you cannot recover from in a
relationship is contempt right
and uh you know when your wife
pops into your head you kind of have an
eye roll
like you've lost all
respect for her the way you're
describing her and then you walk into
the room and she feels that and every
defense mechanism she has spins up and
then you get in this weird dance where
she's defending herself against you and
you're defending yourself against her
crazy cycle right and that's like I I
will often say somebody has to be the
adult stop the music stop the dancing
turn the lights on and say what are we
doing we are choosing misery at this
point let's let's choose something
different are you in right yeah and uh
sometimes like man I found myself like
Daniel getting frustrated over time with
the way my wife was responding to things
until I realized oh she's responding to
me the way I talk the way I communicate
the way I announce what we're going to
do instead of sitting down coming to the
table and I've also run across people
who's
um get dragged around by their wives and
others so I mean who knows what the
actual route here is but they need to
sit down and be adults and say what are
we doing yeah I think you're way overdue
to sit with a marriage counselor yeah
way overdue and you need to sit down
with them
um but uh
I I'm I'm gonna Venture and say I'm we
don't know any details except what is
said here that this is a a young
marriage uh with young people and
um could be old people that are just
doing
dumb young things but um but that that's
I I'm gonna put it on you Daniel you
said I've tried talking to her but she
always and I think that tells me that
you've tried talking at her right like a
parent to a child yeah like this is what
we need to do and we're gonna sell your
car yeah
another scheme I've got for it yeah
here's something else we're going to do
this and instead of saying all right
I'm worried
I'm scared about money and I'm scared
about our relationship if we don't get
on the same page about what our dreams
are and what our future is going to look
like if we don't start dreaming together
again and then discussing how to get
there this stuff around baby steps and
budgeting and financial goals and all
that has woken that up inside of me that
I want us to have a shared Vision shared
goals shared fears and we don't have
that and it's worrying me what have we
got to do to get that going and that's a
that is an honest question coming from
coming from your need and if that gets
her angry now you got real problems
right right but that probably is I think
the reason she's angry she's tired of
being talked at right and uh yeah
there's something that different between
I'm scared versus here's how you're
gonna budget those are two different
conversations I'm putting you on a
budget yeah yeah that'll fly those are
they should be filed under things to
never say to your wife yeah lead weight
balloons yeah that's just not going that
one's not going anywhere yeah so if if
some simple things like that Daniel like
reapproaching this and going look I'm
sorry I came at this wrong but it's
scaring me and it's a big deal to me
that we learned to work together on this
and you getting mad and stopping off the
other room I can't deal with it it's
freaking me out
and so what can we do to where we can
sit down and talk about our future and
how we can win together on life and it
does show up in our checkbook
um and if she says screw you then you
know you may you know you then you
really have to sit down the marriage
counselor but it may just be on how to
end the marriage right because admit
that it already ended
um but that's the thing so yeah you're
pretty much going it alone right now son
so I think you got to make some moves to
fix that one way or the other either you
get her to the table or you get her to a
marriage counseling table or if she
won't go you go without her go talk to
the marriage counselor and let them
teach you how to talk yeah and and
before we move on from The Stave well I
think this is important to call out he
writes here at the end at times it feels
it feels best if we part it ways
I always think about carrying a whole
bunch of groceries up and I'm a guy that
likes to carry all the groceries at the
same just make one trip and I've got 14
bags on one arm and something on my head
and something on my other arms
and it I always overload myself it
always gets too heavy and I always think
I need to set all this stuff down
and if I just set the groceries down
it's going to feel it's gonna feel good
for a minute and then I'm gonna have
wasted all these groceries we're gonna
have no food upstairs I'm gonna have two
loud kids who are hollering at me
sometimes what feels best right this
second is not the solution long term for
your relationship you gotta take the
hard path you got to do hard stuff and
sit down and have uncomfortable
conversations if you're going to get to
a place of Peace on the other end Craig
Rochelle Pastor Craig's new book he
talks about one of the things that
causes people to have positive change in
their life is when they choose the right
heart or the hard right the hard right
the hard thing that's the right thing
yeah choose the hard right the thing
yeah and
um she's the hard thing that's the right
thing and that's what you're talking
about here and it's choose to push
through this choose to get to the bottom
of it choose to own your part of it and
apologize repeatedly and choose to move
okay what is going to get us to the
place we really want to be when we're 85
years old Emily is with us Emily is in
Illinois Champaign to be precise hi
Emily how are you
Hi how are you guys we're great we're
right up against the clock go for it
I wrote this down to keep it quick so I
I Certified Financial coach for a local
Credit Union and my husband let his life
insurance last
so it's been two months and it doesn't
matter what I say he won't get life
insurance how come a Certified Financial
coach is not doing a budget with your
husband where you knew that it wasn't
being paid
so it comes out annually
and this is our we've only been married
for nine months so this is our first
go-around with that
and I was like hey you need to check
that it hasn't come out of the account
that was supposed to come out can you
check that and he was like no I think
it's bumped in with yours and I'm like
that's not how that works
um
and
this since then the last two months so
why does he not want to take care of you
with his life insurance
I don't know I think that's the issue
that's what I'd get to the bottom of
yeah I think that conversation sits down
and you look across the table from him
and say I am terrified and scared to
death of what happens to me when you die
will you please help me here yeah that's
what it's for take care of you it's not
for him
he doesn't need the life insurance you
do if you're the beneficiary that is
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Greg is next in
Oklahoma City hi Greg welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
let me start out I'm 61 Dave
and my dad passed and he left the kids
each one of us some money okay I have
fifty thousand dollars Dave
um I know I'm late to the game
um so and I lost a lot and then divorce
but my savings is twenty thousand
my 401k is 70 000.
my emergency fund is ten thousand
my house is uh
I have a balance of 85 000 so
um do I go towards the
paid the house
down
or do I need to invest that money dude
and John what do you make Greg
50. 50. okay well here's our goal okay
the two things that will give you
stability
in your later years
okay is a paid for house
and a nest egg
so we need both
and as you said you're late to the game
you're you're running behind on both of
them
the good news is you didn't have an 850
000 mortgage you get an 85 000 mortgage
that's really good news
and you got a little and you don't have
a bunch of debt I hear or no other debt
other than the house
right yes sir good good all right so
what I would do is pay it on the house
with the idea that I'm gonna get the
house paid off of the rest of the way
very very soon
lean in on that and while you're doing
that let's get that 401k jacked up and
get it going you got to throw money at
it so I got two big goals massively fund
the 401K and knock out that final 35 000
so that when you get to 65 or 70 you've
got two or three four hundred thousand
dollars in your 401k and a paid for
house that'll set you up
but you've got you're gonna have to do
all of it because you you got some
catching up to do you have to lean in
not nothing to panic about it's very
doable but um
you need to save all you can into your
401k and clear the rest of that house
with great urgency
uh you know because you basically got
four or five six seven years to finish
this deal up because if you can go into
retirement with enough of a nest egg
that you can live off of the income and
have no debt at all including your house
that's a very stable
you know anxiety free retirement
right okay right how far how long can
you do your job is it a manual labor job
you got a couple years left or can you
do this for the next eight nine years
hey I can go my goal is eight but I'll
just go part-time at eight just to keep
busy and get still have some money and
what do you do
uh Parts specialist okay all right
that's cool and you know what I would do
probably if I were you I like the idea
of getting a head start and kind of
getting this kicked off so I probably
would say I'm going to commit to 24
months of uh unreasonable work
and just you know go see if you can
double your income for 24 months by
kicking some side hustle in the teeth
I don't want you to do that forever yeah
and you've worked hard but I would like
to get to where I'm a hot you know
because that right there would clear the
house and you could load that 401k full
you see what I'm doing and if you're you
said you're 60. so if you're 62 and you
got a paid for a house and now we've got
a hundred and forty thousand in your
401k heading towards three four hundred
I feel really good about your situation
then don't you
yeah yeah I was afraid you're gonna go
you're gonna say that you know but
you're right you're right yeah I'm late
and again I would rather you do it now
and get all of that oomph going get that
momentum going get the rock rolling down
the hill then have to do it at 70.
or can we can we can we do an
uncomfortable exercise real quick Greg
yeah yeah and this is for the benefit of
the listeners
imagine yourself the next 24 months
working really hard you're driving Uber
in the morning you're driving Uber in
the evening after you get off of work
you're tired you're going home your 60
year old joints ache you've got that
and also Imagine at 70 you're sitting in
your house and you pick up your landline
and you call your brother and you've got
to ask him for some money
it's either or you see how it's either
or here yeah
yeah one of these is going to leave you
with dignity with your head held high
with I I went out on my shield I I put
the my pedal to the middle and the other
one is
can you come rescue me because I didn't
I didn't I didn't have the courage to go
make it happen and we're doing this with
a sense of urgency towards
ambition and succeeding and prospering
not a sense of desperation right because
you'll get desperate after a while if
you don't do it now with that sense then
it'll that the emotional turn on it and
it'll feel
like terror is driving this and I think
if I think back to the last 30 years of
you asking Congress nicely and
increasingly with louder and louder
volume
we're going to deal with this at some
point we can deal with this
intentionally or we can deal with it
when it drops on our head yeah we've got
to deal with it exactly Aaron is in
Rochester Minnesota hi Erin welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi
it's good to be on here good to have you
how can we help hey
I'm a 30 year old Pastor I'm married and
I have two kids and we're on baby step
3B with four and five also being worked
on and I've been going through your
Financial Peace University for pastors
and I really appreciate that oh good
um yeah we live in a parsonage though
and a small house immediately behind us
will be coming up for sale in the next
couple of years and we were wondering if
we should buy it and rent it out for
additional income because we'd like to
buy a house in the country but we feel
like we should have a little bit bigger
income before we take that step
so you're buying a rental property
to hedge against the fact that someday
you're going to walk out of a parsonage
and you want to have participated in the
real estate world
exactly okay are you gonna pay cash for
it
no
we would have to get a loan on it what
denomination do you serve in
Baptist
okay
is it fair am I accurate my perception
is and I work with 50 000 churches over
the past um 30 years my perception is
that parsonage with a Baptist Church is
fairly unusual
um it kind of depends on where you're at
it's becoming more unusual which is kind
of nice for the pastors anyway mm-hmm
yeah I mean because you can you can do
uh housing allowance you can do all
kinds of things that in the pasture
World from a tax perspective uh and how
you receive your pay if you don't have a
parsonage and I just don't know that
maybe other churches have one anymore I
see I see a personage a lot more often
with uh old school Presbyterian or
methodists than I do with Baptist by the
way just as an aside yeah but um yeah
yeah so it's much more common there
because again Methodist they'll turn
over a pastor and move them around more
than Baptist does Baptist you're there
till they run you off and so
um or vice versa you run them off but um
but you're not senior pastor or you said
you said youth pastor
no I'm a senior pastor you've ever seen
that I've been here for nine years okay
so you're gonna be there a while
probably okay all right
hey that's why I was trying to think
through that in general is are you
really going to be in that situation the
whole time and you may be you may be
right
um
I'm gonna move yeah I mean if you want
to do that and say that's my house in a
way uh because that gets you
participating in the real estate market
you've got to do some kind of an
investment plan
long term that we call your house fund
yeah we call when the parsonage ends
what am I going to move into fund
yeah it's not about 8 000 saved up for
that right now yeah and if you throw
that at that house if you throw that at
that house and you keep building it up
between now and the time you purchase
that house and then get that house paid
off even if that's not the house you
move into that is an investment that we
can liquidate to be your fund for buying
your home on the parsonage ends so I'm
okay going that yeah I probably would do
that
cool yeah all right thank you very much
yeah but the the idea your the good news
is you're being very intentional on the
whole idea of housing after the
parsonage and a lot of pastors a lot of
missionaries we work with have not made
plans for how they're going to live in
retirement where because you got to have
a physical location to live in yeah and
you've been living in someone else's
housing for decades in some cases so you
really really have to plan for how this
is going to end well or it doesn't so
good for you Aaron uh pastors out there
we are having free pastors classes for
Financial Peace University check it out
at ramsaysolutions.com
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth the work that you love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John baloney show is my co-host the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right Heather is going to start off
this hour in Cincinnati hi Heather
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um well long story short
um I became the primary care provider
for my elderly neighbor in 2018. he
um
did an amazing job throughout his life
of saving money and he left me the sole
inheritor of his estate which is valued
about three hundred thousand dollars wow
foreign
we have I worked really hard with him to
you know make sure like when I started
helping him with his finances when he
took his car got paid off he was debt
free except for his house and he was
already retired so we
um about two years ago we started
putting an extra 400 down on his
mortgage based on your principles
um
so now I have this estate and I want to
make sure that I do justice to him and
his hard work and being financially
responsible with it
and I have a couple questions and I
didn't know who to ask so I figured I'd
turn to Uncle Dave because Uncle Dave is
wise and Uncle Dave is impartial and
Uncle Dave is going to give me some hard
truths that I prom might not want to
hear
well we'll try to love you well I'm
sorry for what you've gone through I
would imagine you guys were close
yeah he was my best friend
I hate that for you um
you're single
I am married oh you're married okay yes
I am married um my husband and I just
went through a very rough patch over the
past couple of years
um and it resulted in our emergency fund
is down to eleven hundred dollars from
12 000 last year went through a rough
patch in your marriage or in your
finances sure in our marriage okay all
right how you doing now
we are a lot better with a lot of prayer
and a lot of counseling we are in a lot
better spot good so okay very very good
what can I help you with
um well I think the biggest question
that I have is
um
the house is valued about 189 thousand
dollars there's
um 46 533 left on the balance for the
mortgage
um it's a 30-year fixed at 5.75 but
again we've paid off an additional ten
thousand dollars over two years by just
adding an extra 400 a month
um our plan is to you know update the
house and clean it up and rent it out
[Applause]
so um I think our biggest question on
the house is should we pay off the
mortgage with the estate yes or would we
okay because I've been given some advice
from a couple of friends we're like no
keep a mortgage because it's a business
and I was like your friends are idiots
you had a good best friend because the
other ones are not that great
we're going to get rid of the mortgage
and so the house has Equity of about 100
so how much other money is there in the
estate
um well we've got about 66
000 between checking and savings 10 000
invested in a bond but it's been
invested for two years and hasn't done
anything he's made more money off of his
savings account than he has this Bond so
we were going to close out the bond and
then there's a ten thousand dollar life
insurance policy
and um you've got you've got eighty
thousand dollars cash give or take
yes and then we've got a 2010 Buick
LaCrosse with less than seventy Thousand
Miles sitting in the garage
sell it okay what will it bring
um between eight and nine thousand okay
so we got ninety thousand dollars cash
and we have a thirty five thousand
dollar mortgage we write a check and pay
off the mortgage we put some money in an
account to do whatever minor Renovations
you do mistake number one brand new
landlords make is they build up a rental
house as if they wanted to live in it
it's not your house it's a rental house
yes sir and whatever you do you're going
to end up doing over in five years
anyway so don't spend more than is
necessary to make the home reasonably
appealing to the rental market in that
price range
okay don't overspend on the rehab
yes sir as if you were trying to somehow
make his house nice again with him
having gone to heaven or somehow uh
first first two rentals I did I did in
my 20s but the first two I did I fixed
them up way too nice
like Sharon and I were going to move in
them or something you know and we you
know that we weren't the market for that
particular house so that's you know you
fix it up nice enough to fit that market
because you're going to spend the money
again anyway so that shouldn't be a lot
of money he was uh the ha the house was
in half was habitable he was in it so
you know coat of paint maybe some carpet
some light rehabs through kitchens and
stuff but don't go in there and start
just completely gutting this thing and
spend 100 000 on it I would not do that
hey Heather can I ask you a hard
question
yeah
Let's Pretend your friend was still with
us
were you and your husband wanting to get
into the real estate business
um we had entertained the idea but given
our finances
um we were not going to be looking to
get into the real estate business
anytime soon do you guys have a bunch of
personal debt that you all need to clear
up
no sir the only debt that we have to our
name right now other than our mortgage
is one car loan with about 7 500 left on
it yeah write that check too that's
right and how much is your mortgage
balance
our mortgage balance is currently about
ninety six thousand
um we refinanced in 2020 to a two and a
half percent 15-year fixed rate you need
to pay that off as soon as possible too
so whatever you don't spend on this
rehab which should be the majority of
this money so Thirty forty thousand
bucks or so needs to go on your mortgage
oh wait man we paid off your car so
twenty or thirty thousand dollars needs
to go on your mortgage pay off your car
do a light rehab pay off the mortgage on
the rental and then let's get your house
paid off as soon as possible
out of line to fully fund our emergency
fund before we do anything with our
mortgage no that would be in baby steps
that's perfect
yeah let me tell you this Heather um I'm
I've moved several times over the last
you know 10 15 years and my granddad
passed away and he left me this before
he had died he'd given me this really
cool
um like suit jacket and it didn't fit
I'm a little bit bigger than him but I
always cap it and I always liked it and
it I would put it on every once in a
while but usually I put on when I was
moving and I was like I'm keeping this
one in this last time we moved
um to the house that we live in now I
moved it over to the keep pile
and I'll never forget I had I was all by
myself I had a pile of clothes and I
took that jacket and I looked at it and
said my granddad's not inside this
jacket and I put my hand on my chest and
said my granddad's here
and my son comes bebopping up the stairs
and I said to my granddad's there
he's not in this jacket this jacket
doesn't fit and I'm carrying it around
trying to preserve these memories and
that's not where the memories are the
memories are inside my heart and I put
that jacket in the giveaway pile and so
sometimes we keep stuff because we want
to hang on to these people they're with
us whether we got that stuff in that
junk or not
[Music]
hey guys if you're planning to move
sometime soon that's awesome I'm excited
for you but you got to be real too in
most places around the country you'll
still be facing high home prices
interest rates aren't exactly returning
to the record lows doesn't make home
ownership impossible though if you want
to buy or sell you want to make sure
you're financially ready and that you've
got trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk with you through the
process not some family friend who just
got their license or some guy who does
Real Estate it's a part-time hobby you
can find a high caliber high octane high
protein Ramsey trusted endorsed local
provider agent through our endorsed
local provider program and since we vet
the agents from around the country
you'll have the best support whether
you're moving from Florida to Alaska or
anywhere in between
ramseysolutions.com agent to find a
Ramsey trusted real estate agent today
ramseysolutions.com agent by the way if
you're thinking about buying a home uh
interest rates went down this week
I don't know how long they'll stay down
but it's a really good time to think
about getting in the Market at this
second one of the results of the uh
SVP Bank debacle is a bond market got
upset and uh went the other way for a
change and rates dropped you know in
some cases quarter half a point
depending on that so good time to get a
mortgage locked in with Churchill
Mortgage good time to see an ELP and uh
get a house deal going
um I don't know I suspect these rates
will settle back up to where they were
that this is a temporary thing
emotionally driven off of this bank
failure but um I don't know hopefully
they'll stay down I'd love for them to
stay down but um good time to get in if
you're sitting on the sidelines for some
reason or another this is the time
Drew's with us Drew is in Seattle hi
Drew welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey there it's great to be on good to
have you how can we help
hey well um life's been extra special
for me and I feel like having kind of
opened up for my wife and I the last a
month or two we've had a very gracious
gift from our in-laws given to us with a
big amount of cash and so we're trying
to just figure out just how to set us up
for kind of the future in the best way
um I feel like I'm just kind of getting
different ideas polling of
you know whether to put it towards part
of it towards retirement you know get
that going you know have a couple kids
you know maybe start a little bit of
their college fund and we have yet to
purchase our first home
um and so if you do not have a home
we do not have a home
um my wife and I were both 29 years old
um we have two kids how much was the
gift
it was a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars which is I'm still kind of Blown
Away saying that out loud well what's
the basis for the gift
so they um both my and my mother-in-law
and father-in-law they retired this last
year
um during covert they were able to sell
their house and downsize and they were
able to sell it you know obviously for
way more than they had anticipated given
the
uh hind placement about homes during
covet and
um they were being more than generous to
us and so it was just that hey here's a
gift and if you want to do it towards
kind of your mortgage or whatever you
feel is best you know here you go did
they do that in this calendar year
in 23. yes good okay please as a sidebar
get in touch with them and make sure
that they have gotten some tax advice
because there is no way I'm sorry
go ahead no what were you gonna say
oh no yeah we did get attacked uh
involvement with making sure
everything's just reported correctly and
that they have known
um I guess tax against them in the year
23.
yeah reporting I guess for the year 2020
yeah well it won't be gift taxed if they
did a unified gift tax exemption form if
they do not do that they will get a gift
tax on this of 50 or 75 000 tax
so yeah yeah they really need to do it
right that's why I was concerned and it
sounds like these people are
this is their first rodeo on this type
of thing so just make sure that they've
done that okay you don't have any tax
issues but they could if they haven't
done this right now what would I do if I
were 29 years old a couple kids didn't
own a house I got 150 000 uh you have
any other debt
yes that's kind of what I'm calling in I
feel like I already know the answer
um I do have 85 000 in student loans oh
good lord okay
well what I would do is
um it's not it's not fun
but I would be debt free and have an
emergency fund and then the rest of us
are down payment towards the house
yeah
and so you know yes you got you got 50
000 to put down on a house is what it
amounts to
you pay off yeah we have um we have some
paid up on the side about 30 000
um since I came out of school a few
years ago
um and we have our emergency fund okay
well Drew you're fairly new to our stuff
apparently we teach a process called the
baby steps
and it's the shortest right way from
where you are to wealth
it's not what you've been doing but it's
how we teach people to get there okay
and baby step one is a thousand dollar
safe two is debt free but your house
that frees up your income which is your
largest wealth building tool larger than
the gift you got by the way what is your
income by the way
okay great great income okay so now what
we're trying to do is get this income
freed up to make you more money so we
got to get rid of the student loans and
any of the debts that you have that's
the only debt you have is student loans
yes okay so yeah you're debt free when
you get this check and you put an
emergency fund aside that's maybe step
three three to six months of expenses
you start saving fifteen percent of your
income towards retirement and you've got
you should have fifty thousand dollars
or so left over to put as your down
payment on your house and that gets you
into a house on a 15-year fixed rate
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay then you're
putting fifteen percent of your income
away into retirement you start your kids
college funds and then maybe step six is
we get this house paid off and that's
going to take seven eight years and
that's you know so by the time you're 40
you should have a paid for house
and you should have several hundred
thousand dollars in mutual funds in your
401k and your kids college ought to be
well underway if not taken care of by
then
uh you've got the money to do all of
that if you follow this but it's not you
know it's not like woohoo I got 150 000
let's do something cool with it
I gave you five thousand nursing student
loan debt
so you don't get any woohoo moment with
this I'm sorry you do grown-up stuff
with this oh that hurts so man I heard I
hurt for you man
yeah
I might take uh five thousand dollars to
go do something fun
you know take the family on a trip or
something I might do that out of this to
have a little bit of woohoo out of it
but really I mean I'm just going to call
on you to be a grown-up and do smart
stuff with it
um and because that's what's going to
put your family if you live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else is going to put you in the best
position to win long term and uh now
you're going to have a whole lot of
people tell you to do a whole lot of
stupid butt stuff other than that but
they're going to be what's known as
wrong there's nothing else on the planet
I know a lot about Drew but this this
stuff I got this down
I'm the best there is at this and if
you'll do this stuff it'll change your
whole dadgum life in your family tree so
do it the way we're teaching hold on I'm
going to pay for you to go through
Financial Peace University our nine-week
course on how to handle money you and
your wife go through that and it'll show
you exactly what I'm talking about and
why to do this and we'll help you get
not only uh the rest of the way out of
debt not only get this thing paid on not
only get this house paid off but move in
the right direction here
oh yeah again I heard for you but
there's there's not another way yeah you
got you just it's the hard you know
we're talking about it in another
segment it's a hard right that's right
the Ride Hard whatever it is I can't
ever get it right hard right the right
thing to do that's hard and that's just
you know the kids call it adulting but
it's just grown-up land I mean it's just
and there's also going to be some pride
conversation with with their in-laws who
might feel like well I didn't know
you're gonna pay off your your student
loans with this I thought we were gonna
right and that just made me part of it
they gave you that money and that is
what it is yeah but that's that's what
you should do with it regardless of
whose opinion
uh his cross purposes with that it
doesn't really matter to me um that
that's exactly what you should do with
it
um when we're kids Dave like a hundred
thousand dollars
felt like it would solve every problem
on Earth
and when you're like 100 000 will just
get you started on creating problems
right it's like a lot will mostly get
done with your student loans and it's
like oh that hurts it hurts but you
gotta act like an adult man yeah this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones are triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money
by the way if you guys have been blessed
by this show we could use your help and
many of you have been responding to this
request by based on the numbers we're
seeing so thank you the request is
pretty simple if you are watching or
listening to the show uh in digitally in
a podcast or YouTube or something like
that you've got the mechanism to share
the show with your friends with a link
do that share the show
subscribe to the show follow the show
depending on what the format is you're
doing this you can share the show if
you're watching it on TBN or watching or
listening to the show on Radio 680 radio
stations carry this show every day uh
that by just telling your friends about
it
that's how you share it just say hey
have you guys been listening to such and
such a radio station in the afternoons
in the mornings that's when Ramsay show
is on and you ought to listen to it it's
pretty incredible thank you for sharing
it following it subscribing lastly leave
a review if in the digital settings
leave a five star review one Stars don't
help uh don't help anybody they don't
even help you feel better so if your
mother said if you don't have anything
nice to say don't say anything at all so
leave a five-star review and all of
those three things sharing subscribing
and five star reviews really drive the
algorithms that cause the listenership
to go up and cause us to be able to help
more people and that's what we're here
for so thank you thank you for that
because we're seeing our numbers rise
dramatically this year all right
Valerie's with us in Sacramento hi
Valerie welcome to the Ramsey Show
oh thanks for taking my call Dave last
time I heard you speak I was with my 12
year old son and he has been Frugal ever
since he saw you so wow thank you for
that
um and I'm calling today I'm selling my
cabin
um that is currently buried in snow in
Tahoe and I'll be making about 388
000. my question is should I take the
proceeds of the cabin and pay off my
mortgage which is 200 000 and I have
roughly 50 000 in other debt or take
that money to buy a another similar
place in a place with no snow where I
could collect about 1500 in rent
if your home was paid for would you
borrow on it to buy a rental property
wow Hey listen listen I gotta I if you
were standing here I'd high five you
most people lie to Dave and you didn't
so congratulations at least you told the
truth it's insane what you said but you
told the truth and so that's good
the shortest distance between where you
are and a high quality Financial life
including wealth building is to get your
home and your debt paid off
then use the cash flow that's freed up
in the increased peace of mind
to rapidly pile up cash and buy rental
property since you like rental property
but um now I would pay off your home in
your debt and then I would rep you know
whatever's left beyond that make sure
you have an emergency fund and then
beyond that if you want to start saving
aggressively to buy rentals since you
love rentals um that's fine I don't have
an issue with that that's what I did
I've got a bunch of real estate but I
pay cash for everything I do not borrow
money and Valerie I'm going to ask you a
question but I I'm actually asking it to
Dave Valerie how much is your mortgage
every month in your in your primary home
it's 1400 a month I have about a three
percent interest rate on it so let's
throw in just throw the interest rate
and stuff all that out you are willing
to mortgage your home your primary
residence
for fifteen hundred dollars a month in
um cash flow
by paying off your house don't you hit
that exact Benchmark by freeing up 1400
to 1500 a month in cash flow
uh yes now I know why you're sitting
next to Dave but you do you get the
exact same dollar amount and you have
zero none no risk
yeah you have to worry about the rent or
not paying or snow falling in San Diego
or whatever happened this year yeah
okay that makes perfect sense
you know what I did in your situation
was I said okay 1500 1400 I just said
all right that means that I can set up a
mutual fund for 3 000 a month
where I used to have a house payment and
I don't anymore and I had a little slop
in the budget right and I'm gonna see
how fast that three thousand dollars a
month becomes a million dollars in a
mutual fund uh it never made it to a
million because I bought real estate for
it not too big but I used that my old
house payment mutual fund is what I
called it to see how fast I would build
wealth as a result of being debt free
you see what I'm doing
and then that that got me there really
really quickly and then you buy rentals
with cash as you go and that moves
everything along so well done very done
that's a cool cool thing you made some
money in Tahoe
um you know dig the closing papers out
from under the snow and get your check
and let's go works for me every time
Dan's with us in Orange County hey Dan
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you for having me sure how can we
help
yeah so um I'm currently in Southern
California I'll be graduating soon this
year and we'll have my first job in
Northern California while I have to move
and I have about five thousand dollars
saved up in cash
and uh some Investments as well and I
was wondering if I should save that cash
um in order to move to Northern
California or if I should start paying
down
um the debt that I have in student loans
which is about 90 000.
okay what are you graduating in
I have a master's in business management
good for you and you've already gotten
the job lined up in Northern California
yeah we'll be starting the summer and
making what
uh 150 good for you well done well done
you should end other Investments you
drove by there pretty quick how much is
it and other Investments
yeah I have about uh ten thousand in
Iraq right now okay all right stop doing
retirement
and I have the money to make the move
the five thousand dollars to make the
move is wise because you're going to
make the move and you need the money to
do that and then when you get moved
um let's finish you know let's tear into
the student loans and knock them out
really really fast because you're used
to living like a broke college student
why don't you just keep living like that
and pay this loan off in a year
okay in a year uh yeah
how much do you make this year
um relatively low just had two part-time
jobs what did you make this year
uh around 25 okay and Orange County is
more expensive than where you're moving
to
uh I went to the Bay Area oh no it's not
okay
oops okay you got me so you're basically
earning minimum wage with your 150 000
yeah
okay
I think it's cheaper to live in space
right now than to live in the Bay Area
the uh okay so yeah but what I want you
to do is live on as little as possible
and pay this off and and let's call it
12 to 24 months then
um okay in words you lived on 25 000
this year in Orange County you moved to
the Bay let's call it fifty thousand you
make 150 that leaves you a hundred not
counting taxes
definitely okay and so that's an 18
that's an 18 to a 24 month plan to pay
off 90 grand enlisted Dan this doesn't
get talked about enough man
you're gonna show up there with a bunch
of young folks who are recent grads and
they're all making six figures and there
becomes a flex contest on Whose Tesla
looks the best and whose shoes and don't
play that game man if you can hang in
for 36 months and pay your student loans
off and get yourself four or 24 months
get yourself a head start financially if
you have no payments at all no debt at
all and you make 150 and you're single
just out of school dude you're going to
be set up to make so much money and
build up so much wealth it's going to be
incredible but if you carry that student
loan around like it's a pet because
somebody called that sophisticated then
you're not sophisticated you're just
straight up stupid or you want to buy
some fancy depreciating asset that sits
in a parking garage most of the day just
don't do it man don't do it a battery
with wheels yeah exactly exactly yeah
there you go I mean yeah that that's
what happens so yeah I
good good call there a good call out but
damn be careful be careful to not fall
into the Trap of what everybody else
that you're running with is doing
because they're getting rid of my
classic mistakes that I've watched
happen over and over for 30 years and
John's are making a good point oh I did
dude I graduated from college and I drew
drove a 88 turcell easy hatchback the
size of a large roller skate and I I
want to get the biggest truck I left
College got a great job my first year
and I ended that first year way more
debt than I left college with just being
an idiot man just trying to keep up and
well just trying to Exhale that's right
yeah after holding your breath in school
hold your breath a little while longer
and get out of debt this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Psalms 37 and 4 delight yourself in the
Lord and He will give you the desires of
your heart
Chuck Norris said people need to realize
what real happiness and success are
because success as an actor is fleeting
you can be up there one day and go on
the next
um success in general is fleeting as far
as that type of success goes all right
Mary is going to uh join us now from
Idaho Falls Idaho hi Mary welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um so I'm trying to figure out uh kind
of like my next move on
um what I what I should do for myself
for work
um just to give you a little background
um I
worked in Corporate America and then I
became a doctor
um I have we have no debt except for
what we have on our house a medical
doctor rmd
yes sir okay
um six months we have like the six month
expenses
um I have uh well we have one million
sixty thousand in like 401K Roth IRA I
also because I work with corporate
America also have um when when I when I
will draw on it about a thousand month
pension and so I don't have any med
school loans no you know nothing except
for just the right yeah so we moved from
a really blue state to Idaho
um I was traveling back and forth and my
husband moved up with a few kids so I
could start school and I was traveling
back and forth until
um December of last year and I'm I don't
currently have a job right now my oldest
is having a little bit difficulty with
the transition because
um we moved in the middle of high school
as opposed to starting freshman year
and he's taking advanced classes and
um was having a lot of trouble with
school and so I've that's been a lot of
my main focus and so how many kids you
got my
two one in junior high and one in in
high school okay what's the nature of
the trouble he's having
oh
just electronics and even though like
we're pretty tight on that but just not
doing his schoolwork not turning it in
since like he had
um he has like all advanced classes so
it's not a brain issue uh he currently
has like a 3.8 but it is with me like
really
hey did you turn with it you know just
like uh really on him and so my concern
is that where we live why did he drop it
into neutral
oh just trouble making friends up here
and just yeah so not like no drugs or
anything like that so Mary one of the
one of the operating guidelines that uh
with my own two kids and with folks who
are struggling with kids is
um
relationships connectivity and kids
absorb tension
it is they absorb the adults
um energy in a room that sounds super
woo-woo and it's more sophisticated than
that but parents wandering around what
should we be doing do we make the right
move I don't know about this what am I
going to do kids absorb that
and it comes out all over the place and
um man it makes perfect sense I wouldn't
think twice about having a upset high
school kid that was in the middle of
high school and then got uprooted moved
across the country and that in and of
itself doesn't bother me what bothers me
is what's the plan for reconnect
reconnecting next
and I personally is a parent especially
a parent with as
brilliant as a mom and dad is as the
your kids have
um I would concede a couple of GPA
percentage points for friendships and
connectivity and choosing relationship
with my kids reestablishing that over
winning uh homework arguments on certain
occasions does that make sense
yeah I don't
arguing
you know it just it's just that like I
mean things have turned around here I'm
not I mean I I don't he's doing sports
right now it's just he goes to a larger
school and it's just harder to make
friends if it was him I would just tell
him like Hey you're awkward or let's
work on this but it's just you know it's
not he really has a good personality
he's got a lot of good things for him
things are going better
um because he's playing sports but it's
just been a really long haul and so
yeah right
um I was kind of feeling guilty not
going back to work right now
why
why not going back to work or why
feeling guilty why are you feeling
guilty
I don't know I've worked really hard to
get where I'm at but my family is most
important so I agree
um yeah I make the most out of between
the two of us I make
but way more than my husband we're fine
with just him working and this is not
necessarily a permanent decision
no okay if you take if you take six if
you take six months and get your family
landed in a new city
and you concentrate on 100 mom duties
for six months with the game plan of
we're going back to being an MD after
that then I don't I mean
it's not like you said I'm gonna walk
away from all the work I did to become
an MD and do nothing
you didn't say that you said I gotta
help this kid make the turn
yeah
are you using the kid to help you make
the turn because I don't think you've
made it
what does that mean oh I desire in
December I mean like I know but
literally like
are you settled in are you settled into
the new town
personally no no there you go no we're
we're moving we're gonna we just bought
a house and we'll we'll close in about a
month so no we're we're living kind of
in a glorified Hotel Apartment I mean
it's an apartment but it's it's like
transition because we're six months from
today six months from today the nest
needs to be made new connections and
friendships need to be forming a church
is selected uh we're plugged into
Community we're starting to build new
community we've had people over to our
house for dinner you and your husband
get settled that'll help him get settled
and you know in six months all of that
should be well underway and you can go
back to work with her out hardly any
stress I would have zero guilt about
doing that none okay okay the
intellectual Firepower you have and that
the intellectual Firepower you have in
that uh heart for others you have it's
okay to aim that uh at your family for a
season now this is a transition time
it's not a um it's not required that you
work 60 hours a week because you're not
broke
that's the other thing I mean this is
not your family's not gonna be in
bankruptcy because of this
no not even close you're millionaires
yeah so I mean you know I just never not
worked so it feels weird yeah oh you're
working you're working real real hard
you're exhausted you're just not getting
paid yeah yeah
you've you've been you've been getting
um somebody Pat you on the back in the
check deposits every month and that's
been your validation and it's hard to
get validation from how hard you're
working from a 17 year old who rolls his
eyes at you but that the work you're
doing is real and very very challenging
and very very worthy yeah so I I think
if you said
um
I'm gonna allow myself to feel guilty
after this many months
but until then I have a guilt-free Zone
and give yourself a deadline I don't
care what it is it could be nine months
it could be six months it could be 12
months uh you know but but I think at
some point you're going to want to
re-enter the workforce because that's
who you are and um you don't want to it
sounds like you you get uh enjoyment
from it and uh but you you know uh
there's no guilt at all on taking a
little time a little down time and
getting the family settled yeah and that
that may be a signal that the work has
wallpapered over
an idea that you've got value in and of
itself to your kids and to your husband
to your family and maybe this break
might be the best thing that ever
happened to you I'd recommend having
coffee with people who work at the local
hospital or that work in businesses that
stay connected there the intellectual
stimulation will be good for you I miss
that like man I I so I think it's
important to hang on to but man take
your break take your break take your
break
I think he's saying he doesn't get
intellectual stimulation here I think I
just heard that I mean I'm just saying
I think I heard that that puts us out of
the Ramsey showing the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]